unterwegs mit maximal 70 kilometern in
der stunde und ganz ohne abgase
es sind die letzten 50 kilometer vor dem
ziel das erfolgsrezept so einer reise
das richtige team drei idealistische
studenten aus frankreich und deutschland
das ist gering erster kapitän udo zimmer
zum richtigen ort geführt
das ist remi er ist unser experte für
kommunikation und er ist der ingenieur
der deutsche denn und seiner fragen zum
stromverbrauch oder so gestellt hat
haben wir immer gesagt fragt ludwig aus
einer verrückten idee wurde ein projekt
nach einem auslandssemester in bangkok
wollten sie nicht einfach nach hause
fliegen
stattdessen 20.000 km durch 16
asiatische und europäische länder
die rückfahrt von kevin romy und ludwig
ist ein abenteuer mit einem großen ziel
mit dem zug gefahren weil es eine sehr
gute art ist für elektromobilität und
grüne energie zu werden
vier monate haben sie unterwegs
das ist die letzte pause vor dem ziel
toulouse das stück ist eine
spezialanfertigung
es hat die lange reise ohne größere
schäden überstanden
es funktioniert zu 100 prozent strom
bei idealen bedingungen konnten 15
prozent der energie aus den solarzellen
energie kommt aus den lithium batterie
das einzige was für jeden tag machen
mussten aufladen
doch genau das ist manchmal gar nicht so
einfach
in einigen orten waren in china hatten
wir ein bisschen probleme mit dem
aufladen des typs vor allem am anfang
weil wir noch nicht die kapazität der
batterie kann
einmal mussten wir sogar über einen berg
schieben weil die batterie leer war
12 tonnen wiegt die ökoregion keine
leichte sache
ansonsten haben vor allem die
straßenverhältnisse probleme gemacht und
die widrige witterung kälte und regen
doch was sie trotz aller probleme immer
wieder begeistert die unterstützung der
menschen und ihre gastfreundschaft
kommt mit vielen neuen eindrücken
wer die verschiedenen kulturen und
mensch und mit der überzeugung dass
elektromobilität die zukunft ist
immerhin reicht eine batterieladung für
rund 300 kilometer unterwegs haben sie
immer wieder workshops an universitäten
gegeben und von ihrem projekt berichtet
die vielleicht wichtigste station die
klimakonferenz in paris zusammen mit
anderen umweltaktivisten haben sie
demonstriert welches potenzial
elektrische mobilität hat und gemeinsam
eine rundfahrt durch die französische
hauptstadt unternommen eine ganz
wichtige botschaft die wir vielleicht
auch transportieren können mit der reise
haben wird auch gezeigt elektromobilität
kann spaß machen und es kann auch ein
projekt kann spaß eine halbe weltreise
mit einem ökologischen sinn auch
verbinden
und ich glaube das ist eine ganz gute
ganz gutes ergebnis was wir damit
erzielt haben mit unserer reise
finanziert haben die drei ihr projekt
mit hilfe von sponsoren und für
crowdfunding im internet endlich ist das
ziel erreicht toulouse die krönung eines
großen abenteuers und zugleich eine
abschlussfeier
denn für carroll ludwig ist die reise
gleichzeitig teil ihrer masterarbeit für
den uniabschluss
für alle drei gilt dies ist erst der
anfang ihres engagement für alternative
antriebe ein netzwerk aufzubauen um eben
weiter integrieren und da bin ich auch
natürlich ganz optimistisch dass sie
drei geschaffen werden denn sie machen
das mit viel leidenschaft und auch mit
viel seriosität also natürlich sehr
stolz dass sie das geschafft haben die
grünen pilger werden weiter unterwegs
sein
im zeichen der elektromobilität